نعم في الواقع لازالت المواجهات مستمره في
منطقه واحده وهي منطقه التفاح والدرج التي
تتمركز قوات الاحتلال بها منذ ايام طويله
وتحاول التقدم الى مناطق اخرى لكن تفشل
قوات الاحتلال دائما في تحقيق اهدافها في
ظل المقاومه الشرسه من فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وعلى راسها كتاب القسام فيستمر
القصف المدفعي المتواصل على منطقه شرق حي
التفاح والدرج ومنطقه القرم ومنطقه حي
السنفور التي تقع في منطقه الشج
هذه المناطق التي تتواجد قوات الاحتلال
بها في المناطق الشرقيه وهي التي تشهد
مواجهات ضاريه ولا تستطيع قوات الاحتلال
حتى هذه اللحظه الانتقال الى مناطق اخرى
في ظل بقاء هذه المناطق هي مسرح عمليات
لكن يستمر تحليق طيران الاستطلاع وطيران
الاف الاف 16 بالاضافه الى طائرات الكواد
كابتر تمنع اي مواطن الاقتراب من تلك
المناطق او اي مواطن يحاول الاقتراب يتم
قصفه وقتله بشكل مباشر من قوات الاحتلال
اما عن اماكن تواجد قوات الاحتلال ف ف في
المناطق الشماليه الغربيه لا زالت قوات
الاحتلال تتواجد في منطقه الامن العام
ومنطقه حي الكرامه ومنطقه ابراج المخابرات
هذه المناطق التي لا يستطيع احد الوصول
اليها مع استمرار التحليق المكثف من
طائرات الاستطلاع والطائرات المسيره
طائرات الكواد كابتر التي تطلق بشكل الي
على كل من يحاول الاقتراب على هذه المناطق
وانتشار القناصه الاسرائيليه في هذه
الاماكن امتدادا الى شمال قطاع غزه من
منطقه حي الكرامه الى اقصى شمال قطاع غزه
تتواجد قوات الاحتلال بالاضافه الى منطقه
الشيخ عجلين يبدو ان ان قوات الاحتلال
تتراجع بشكل تدريجي من المناطق التي
تتواجد بها في شمال قطاع غزه دون تحقيق اي
اهداف التي اعلن عنها الجيش الاسرائيلي مع
بدايه هذه الحرب من استعاده اسرى احياء او
او القضاء على حماس وايضا استمر اطلاق
الصواريخ ال ال من هذه المنطقه قبل ايام
اطلقت بعض الصواريخ من منطقه شمال قطاع
غزه وبذلك يكون كل اهداف الاحتلال لم
تتحقق على القضاء على حماس او استعاده
الاسرى او تقزيم قدرات وتقليم قدرات حماس
في منطقه شمال قطاع غزه ويبقى الوضع وهي
على ما هو مواجهات ضاريه مع قوات الاحتلال
ومنع قوات الاحتلال من التقدم الى مناطق
جديده اسمعيل فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الصحي المتردي في مناطق الشمال مع
انهيار النظام الصحي هناك وكما ذكرنا هناك
تكشف لحجم كبير من الاثار التي خلفها جيش
الاحتلال في عدد من المناطق شهداء دون ان
يتم دفنهم واصابات يصعب التعامل معها في
المستشفيات نعم عن المناطق التي انسحب
منها انسحبت منها قوات الاحتلال فتشهد او
نلاحظ تواجد الكثير من الجثث عشرات الجثث
التي تحللت في تلك المناطق بسبب قتل قوات
الاحتلال لهؤلاء المدنيين وتركهم على
الارض لايام طويله ومنع اي مواطن الوصول
لتلك المناطق طالما تواجدت قوات الاحتلال
في هذه المناطق وا لذلك يكون اثار هذه
الجثث متواجد من بعد تحللها بالاضافه الى
ان هذه الجثث تغذت عليها للاسف الحيوانات
و من بين هذه الحيوانات القطط وال الكلاب
تغذت على هذه الجثث وهذا امر موجع جدا
يلاحظ بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من اي
منطقه ان هذه الجثث تركت لايام طويله حتى
تحللت وتعفنت و ظهر على اثار الارض هذا
التحلل وبقيت الهياكل العظميه هي الظاهره
على هذه الارض بالاضافه الى ذلك الواقع
الصحي في مدينه غزه هو واقع صعب جدا حتى
هذهه لا تستطيع التقم الطبيه تشغ غرف
العمليات وهي بانتظار منظمه الصحه
العالميه والامم المتحده للقدوم الى منطقه
شمال غزه كانت وزاره الصحه على موعد من 26
ديسمبر من العام الماضي ان يكون هناك وفود
بعد ان شهدنا حركه وفود ملحوظه كان هناك
الاصل استكمال لهذه الحركه من حركه وفود
التابع لمنظمات العالميه للقدوم الى
المنظمات الصحيه في شمال قطاع غزه لتشغيل
بعض المستشفيات بالحد الادنى ومسانده
التوق الطبيه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه وهذه
الايام لم تاتي هذه الطوا هذه الوفود الى
شمال قطاع غزه لكن استطاعت وزاره الصحه
تشغيل مستشفى الصحابه وثروه الحلوه
ومستشفى الشفاء ومستشفى اصدقاء المريض
ومستشفى الاهلي بالحد الادنى كنقاط اسعاف
اوليه لاسعاف المصابين بالاضافه الى ذلك
مستشفى كمال عدوان ومستشفى العوده في شمال
قطاع في اقصى شمال قطاع غزه استطاعت وزاره
الصحه تشغيل هذه المستشفيات بالحد الادنى
ك نقاط اسعافات اوليه لنجده المواطنين
الذين يتم قصف من قوات الاحتلال ما بين
فينه واخرى شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
الايضاحات اسمع الغل مراسل الجزيره من
مستشفى الشفاء في مدينه غزه